you did a show called lion's den I think
I resent it there might have been
someone sitting next to me who did an
episode who's he's got a name damnit
Lions down I don't know what it is
yeah lion's den was was meant to be my
big follow up to the West Wing and I
should have known that nobody had any
real faith in the show when instead of
letting us shoot it on the studio a lot
they made us shoot in a warehouse next
to a dildo factory seriously you're not
making that up a factory where they made
dildos oh yeah sure absolutely
one time I came to work and there were
there were four no it's absolutely true
it's there and it was like we're all the
porns you remember yeah yeah I'm saying
that I shot the heels were on fire
around the studio and there were a vet
that dildo people were running for the
hills
yeah run dildos in both beating the
flames back but we stayed remember yeah
yeah when's the sunset you could see
like the fires all around it was crazy
unbelievable unbelievable is that dildo
factory still there I think it I think
that's probably still successful
he took his lines dead money and bucks
I'm no dummy
you